cooking is a big part of what makes us
human and that is our natural activity I
mean you know anybody who's ever spent
much time with a kid knows that all kids
love to cook when you're cooking at six
seven eight everybody thinks it's
adorable and they tell you no matter how
horrible it is they tell you how great
it is and so it doesn't occur to you
that you could make a mistake and you
eventually you repeat it because
everybody's like isn't that great and
you become a good cook through cooking
and you can't expect too much of
yourself the first few times we in the
media and I take a certain amount of
responsibility for this have frightened
people away from cooking and so the
first thing I would say is don't think
you have to make perfect meals don't be
afraid of making mistakes we do so much
result-oriented cooking where you know
we're so concerned about what we're
going to end up with that we don't pay
attention to the journey and cooking is
an adventure and you know if you make a
mistake with something that you cook
it's a meal you know there's another one
a few hours later I mean it big deal
find someone you trust say you know
whose recipes do you trust and make a
simple recipe and just find out what a
pleasure it is to give that to someone
that you care about and watch their eyes
light up and their pleasure in something
that you've cooked for them it becomes a
kind of drug I mean once you feed people
wonderful food and they like it you want
to do it again and again and again
you